hello welcome to our daily homeroom live
stream for those of y'all who are new to
this this is a
live stream that we're doing every day
as the name implies uh to keep us
connected and answer questions and
figure out ways to support each other
during this these times of school
closures it's also a forum for you to
ask me and our guests questions and
we're going to have a really interesting
guest today i will remind folks khan
academy we are not for profit with the
mission of providing a free world-class
education for anyone anywhere and we're
able to do the work we do because of
donations from folks like yourself so if
you're in a position to do so please
think about donating to khan academy i
want to give a special thanks to several
corporations that have stepped up in the
last few weeks as we've seen our costs
go higher due to the covet crisis we've
seen our traffic be almost 3x of what it
typically is a special thanks to bank of
america google.org fastly novartis
and
atnt so
with that i want to get right into the
conversation i have a really great guest
today who's going to be able to address
a lot of concerns that i think are out
there lorraine hastings is a vice
president with the college board for
those of you all who are not familiar
with the college board the college board
is a not-for-profit we are partnered
with the college board but the college
board also offers the sat and lorraine
specializes in relations with college
counselors and is an expert on all
things that are going on in the sat
right now and i know there's a lot of
questions and so first of all lorraine
welcome thank you for being here i hope
everything is good with your family in
this times of social distancing
uh maybe a good place to start is you
know what's the lay of the land for
those of us who haven't been fully
keeping track of what's going on with
the sat uh with regards to kovid
well hi sal thanks again for the
invitation to join today
i hope you and your family are well as
well as your colleagues the work you do
at khan academy could not be more
important as it is today as we all learn
to navigate this difficult time
as the college board responds to the
impact of coronavirus our top priorities
are the health and safety of students
and educators
in face of school closures we're
adapting to give students opportunities
to still show their strengths and
continue on the path to college
we're working hard to make the sat
available in school and out of school as
soon as the public health situation
allows
right now public health officials have
made it clear that it is not safe to
gather students in one place
many states have closed school for the
rest of the school year and globally
there is widespread school closures
across 192 countries
last week we announced that we will not
be able to administer the s.a.t as
planned on june 6. if it's safe from a
public health standpoint we will provide
weekend sat administrations every month
beginning in august through the end of
the calendar year
this includes a new administration in
september and the previously scheduled
test on august 29th october the 3rd
november the 7th and december the 5th
and the unlikely and i say unlikely
event that schools do not reopen this
fall
we will provide a digital sat for home
use
we of course would ensure that at home
sat testing is simple
secure
fair and accessible to all and
most importantly valid for use in
college admissions
i know that i've shared a few changes
but sal even though it seems as if
everything is changing there is one
thing that's not changing and that's the
official student practice available for
free anytime through our partnership
with you all at khan academy
no and this is super useful and so just
to make sure that i understand what uh
the college board's position on this is
is as soon as
we're we're through this stay-at-home
order y'all are going to essentially
offer the sct on on the regular schedule
thereafter and offer a few more uh
hopefully you can kind of view these as
maybe makeup so it's a monthly
a time period and so is is your view
that this will be sufficient for you
know for guidance counselors out there
advising students or for students
parents teachers
how do you think this is going to affect
the admissions process do you think this
will be um
kids will have our students will have an
opportunity to
to get in there and and show that
they're college ready on the s.a.t
yes so
we as as as you mentioned sal you're
absolutely correct once we get back
hopefully to the new normal in august
we're going to add a new testing date in
september which we have not had a
september admin before
and by providing monthly testing
beginning in august we are confident
that all students who want an
opportunity to take an sat exam will
have the opportunity to do so
throughout the fall take it more than
once if they so desire
so this once again as counselors
continue to work with students they will
be able to advise them what's the best
administrations they feel students
should be able to take
and i want to encourage everyone
listening uh feel free to put your
questions on youtube and facebook we
have team members who are looking at the
questions and we're going to be able to
surface them up for lorraine or or for
myself if if they're
appropriate so there's a lot of
questions and i you know i definitely
want to underline something you said you
said in the unlikely event uh that we
are still in this crisis in the fall
then you have a uh you you all are going
to try to do a digital version of the
s.a.t similar to what y'all are doing
for the ap and in a few weeks uh so i
want to underline that's in the unlikely
event because we are getting a lot of
questions
around what is that going to look like
how are you going to prevent cheating
etc etc uh but that i'm
i would guess you're still figuring out
if you have to go there
yes and you know a very unlikely event
that we have to do an at-home test test
security is of course one of our highest
priorities and we're going to design a
solution that meets our regular
standards we will have a comprehensive
strict set of protocols in place to
prevent and detect cheating and of
course al we can't share everything
we're going to do because we need to
maximize the effectiveness of the things
that we will be employing to to make
sure that the test is secure
and i have a question from facebook
chris lee asked what about the sat
subject tests
so the we had to cancel the subject
tests that were administered that were
supposed to be administered in june
those are two some of the foreign
language ones and those will be
administered later on in the year and
the normal schedule of subject tests in
the fall will continue that those will
be optioned for students in the fall as
normal
and a question from facebook julian
michael says do you foresee a move to
digital testing regardless of when
schools open and i guess a related
you know in certain standardized tests
not that the college board offers but uh
you know i remember when i took the gmat
you know many years ago it was it was
digital back then is this something that
y'all are thinking about generally or
maybe catalyzed by covid
so
of course we're going to once again i
want to continue to stress
what you said earlier
unlikely event we'll do this
if depending on what happens in the fall
we're aware that some places in the
country in the world may open and others
may not so we are you know we are trying
to prepare to address multiple different
scenarios whether it's a blended
option
we plan on paper and pencil continuing
in the future the at home is only in the
unlikely event that we are not able to
administer paper and pencil
yeah and i'll just triply underline what
you said because we're getting a lot of
questions but this is the questions are
a good indicator of how you know what
people kind of latch on to they're like
digital sat down
changing all that you know well what
you're saying this is in the very you
know that's a reality where covid and it
looks you know hopefully you know knock
on wood uh we have we have a handle on
it now or it's at least hopefully peaked
but this is in the unlikely scenario
that we're still in this full social
distancing scenario august september
october uh which hopefully is unlikely
so people should not index on it too
much
that is correct
we are we're we're going to continue to
monitor the situation around the
coronavirus and we're going to use
whatever we learn to up inform whatever
our approach will be in the future yeah
and i have this question from facebook
makai kiefer and this is a question that
i guess is relevant even before this you
know you hear things about schools being
testing optional many colleges and
universities have stated that they will
not require sat exams for students
applying next year do you know how they
will handle the situation and how
students without sat scores compared to
those
with scorers and how would you advise
students whether to take the sct or not
if and when it becomes available i'd
love your thoughts lauren i i have some
thoughts there too i'm happy to share
sure
so
um
once again um
many colleges
are you know making decisions whether or
not they're going to be test optional in
the fall
we colleges are members of the college
board and we
work with them encourage them to be
flexible
and
different
scenarios different situations as always
flexibility in the admissions process is
very important
for students and colleges have committed
to take that into account
they are aware of the circumstances and
the public health crisis and they will
use that when they're considering test
scores grades extracurricular activities
they are truly emphasizing flexibility
and that's what we keep hearing from
them the best advice for students is
always to reach out to the colleges that
they're interested in and have a
conversation with them
some colleges may not require the sat
but we're still encouraging students to
take the sat if possible to help show
their skills because once again it's a
part of many pieces that go into the
college admissions process and the
stronger your portfolio can be for
college admissions the better your
chance and likelihood of being accepted
at the college that you want to go to
yeah and i'll just i'm i'm spending a
lot of time underlining some very
important things you're saying because
what i've been telling friends and
family members and and even some
questions on this live stream when i've
had you know uh high school juniors ask
me uh what to to do i said exactly that
uh you know it's not that the s.a.t is
just this thing that you have to do
because it's some ritual that goes on
goes on in society
those colleges are getting so many
applications they're trying to determine
who's college ready who's not who's
going to be able to contribute to the
community who's
or in enriching ways and so there's a
lot of things they're going to look at
to make those decisions and so of course
your grades matter your extracurricular
activities matter your essays matter but
but the sat
and things like it are valuable because
it gives a read a signal that in
conjunction with all these other things
do correlate based on you know the
admissions officers i've talked to with
success in college and so
i i would say if you are able to and
it's great that you are offering these
extra testing dates
to take it
because that's going to give you one
more
signal one more data point to colleges
at the same time i would not stress
you know in theory you should never
stress about it you should just you know
do your best and
and life
you know and and then and then see what
choices you have uh but i think if you
have the opportunity to do it uh but
this shouldn't be something that causes
stress because this year more than any
year uh people are definitely very
understanding about uh being flexible
about things but yeah my those are my my
two cents
and and so i always like to remind
students that colleges need students to
survive you know that's that's that's
what they're there for so they are going
to be flexible they're going to work
with students and they're going to do
what's in the best interest of students
yeah
and from youtube this is a good question
enact your future asks will juniors who
miss the sat in april have the test
administered for free at their school
during a weekday or will they have to
take it on one of those weekend days and
and i think this is hitting a point that
a lot of school districts or systems
will administer the test for free during
the week day and then the weekends are
normally something that the families
have to pay for so how are y'all
navigating that
so we will also in addition to this
typical school day schedule that we have
in the fall which is around october we
are giving schools the opportunity for
an additional date for testing in the
fall so schools will have also an
additional opportunity to test students
in the states and districts that do it
for free for students they will have
that opportunity this fall so they will
be hearing more from their schools and
districts and even states about what
that testing schedule will look like
and from youtube this nikhil governor
asks what about the sat for foreigners
is that is they are are they also going
to have access to everything you're
talking about in the u.s
so once again should it be safe to do so
from an enter from a public health
standpoint we're going to provide
multiple sat administrations also
for international students
this includes the new administration in
september
as well as the previously scheduled test
for august october and december
this fall we actually already announced
that we were going to add an additional
opportunity for international students
in august that was pre-coronavirus
and since then we have also added in
september so once again um that's there
and then we are seriously also exploring
the possibility of even providing an
additional international administration
day in the fall in addition to the two
that we have already announced so
absolutely our international students
are very important to
us yeah and from facebook we have two
questions one from tracy mcvetta and one
from katie
budget buttinger and these are
essentially the same question uh which
is uh how fast are we will this will the
scores be from the fall testing
administrations uh and i i guess the
obvious question you know a lot of
students would have taken it this spring
and then seen their scores and said oh
do i you know
is this a good score for me to use for
my applications uh so how are y'all
thinking about that
so we we absolutely want to make sure
that students have their scores and time
to make decisions
to register for an additional testing if
that's what they need so we will be
working quickly to make sure students
have this their
scores and one question let's see from
facebook zomi zma says
why can't the sat be administered in
july i think i know the answer but i'd
love your thoughts sorry
well once again um we continue to to
look at what the health situation is um
many
we many of
our test centers are actually schools
high schools college campuses
and
you know we still are not confident we
don't know if things are going to be
available in july and we thought you
know august gives us a good safe
distance hopefully we will be past this
crisis and the last thing we want to do
is to have students register for another
test that we end up having to reschedule
or cancel so we're trying to just go
with the safe option
and following
once again we we continue to follow
what's going on
we monitor activities in the state
across the world because we want to make
sure it is absolutely safe and secure
for students to to test
and uh from facebook gabriella
zlaghi asks um is one date in august and
september going to be enough given all
the backlog of people wanting to take
the test so that kind of goes to a
capacity issue
you know sometimes you can't find your
date because maybe it fills up at your
local testing centers are you all going
to be addressing that as well
yes so two things with that cell
for each administration we're preparing
to significantly expand our capacity for
students to take the test as soon as
schools reopen
we are calling on our member schools and
colleges as well as local communities to
open their doors and provide additional
test center capacity
so every student who wants to test will
also be able to test in addition to that
students who registered for june and
also those in the class of 2021 who do
not have sat scores will also have early
access to registration and we're going
to get back to students
about what this actually means and what
what they need to do
but our top priority will be make to
make sure that students
in the class of 2021 which are the
rising seniors who don't have an sat
scores get the seat that they need so
that they won't have to worry about
not being able to find some place to
test
yeah and i think that's once again worth
emphasizing because there's other
questions we're getting like from
facebook ilana miller uh you know
suggesting multiple testing dates and i
know multiple testing even more than
what you're already offering is hard
because you have to create new tests and
test securities but to your point people
shouldn't be concerned about capacity
issues uh because
that that's in in place
so we we have a question let's see it
actually just disappeared but i thought
it was an interesting question around
fee waivers
you know there's a lot of families going
through economic hardship right now who
might have had you know who might not
have qualified for free waivers uh a
month ago but now uh things have changed
uh how are you all looking at that
process
so fee waivers we have fee waivers for
students who need fee waivers students
should contact their school their
counselor
we actually
since we know schools are closed right
now so there's not the paper waiver that
students can get
out counselors will have access to
digital fee waiver codes that students
will be used to register and get their
test fees waived as long as they meet
the requirements for fee waivers
yeah and from youtube ashley pascal asks
if a test is rescheduled uh will
students be able to apply the payment to
a new date
yeah so the june test that was cancelled
students will be able to
reapply that to a fall registration when
registration opens up in may
if a student there's a lot of um
go ahead
and relate to that i know this gets into
a little bit of logistics of it and i
you know the people asking questions
about oh my march date got cancelled and
uh they're thinking about things like
refunds and you know i i will go to your
defense where i think everyone is
trying to process everything right now
uh but how you know i what assurances
can you give families that no you're
going to be able to get to it and they
will
everything will work you worked out
fairly
yeah you know we just asked just be a
little patient with us we too have been
affected
by coronavirus our customer service
agents have had to find new ways to work
from home so things may not be happening
as quickly as we would like but we are
working on it and um just just just work
with us
we're not going to disappoint
you yeah
and let's see if i'm looking at the
other questions so we've covered a lot
of this
um still more questions about the
subject tests what specific dates they
will be offered
uh any any i guess i mean you already
answered that to some degree
and your extra color on your channel
should just go online the schedule is on
on the website uh but if the subject
test in the fall will have the the
normal schedule that will resume in the
fall the ones that we had to reschedule
from januar from june
as soon as we get those rescheduled
students will know but we're trying to
get those rescheduled by the end of this
year
yeah and from instagram we got this
question actually this is a very
relevant one because we at the khan
academy layer we've gotten certain
questions around this from even school
districts
this uh instagram user says i'm a junior
should i keep studying for the next sat
and i guess there's two things in there
which is you know you got four or five
months until the august test date and
then there might be people who are like
well i can do official sat practice i
can take practice tests but will the sat
you know if we could do that will it
look different what would you say to
folks like that
we should absolutely keep studying uh we
i think sal from your results at khan we
see that the more hours that a student
spends studying the better their
performance on the test
so absolutely keep studying whether or
not you know we have the paper and
pencil and once again worst case
scenario we have to do an at-home sat if
you keep studying you will be prepared
for whatever form of sat gets
administered this fall
and i'll just double down on that you
know what i've been telling a lot of
parents and teachers and students
especially students who are high school
aged right now is
one of the best things you know people
say how should i use khan academy and on
kind of we have a lot of subjects uh you
know going all the way to fairly
advanced math and science and all that
but i've told high school students if
there's one and as early as ninth
graders if there's one thing that you
know if you just even have 30 minutes a
day 40 minutes a day
try the official sat practice and it's
not just so that you eventually when you
take the sat you do well it's because
it's actually making you ready for
college it's aligned to the standards
it's aligned with the skills that
actually matter for college it's math
it's reading and writing you can get
feedback on writing and so if over the
next five or six months you're able to
put in 30 minutes 40 minutes a day every
couple of weeks take a full length
practice test
i i guarantee you i guess of money back
guarantee it's all free so i guess i can
afford to do that but but i i will i
will i will guarantee you with our
reputation that if you're able to put
that time in you focus on that practice
that feedback try to level yourself up
on the various skills we have plenty of
efficacy studies lorraine was just
referring to that show that that time
put in really pays off and we've seen
efficacy studies that six hours from the
between the psat and the sct
is associated with 50 percent greater
than expected growth so you have what
you can do way more than six hours given
uh the amount of time that you might
have on your hands between now and and
back to school so i think uh the
official sat practices way not just to
do well in the set which i think it will
help you there but it'll help you really
thrive when you go back to school
whether you're a senior whether you're
going to be a junior a junior senior
sophomore or or freshman
see other
let's see from nazi guy on instagram
says what changes will be added to the
sat course on khan academy i'll take
that you know the sct is still the sat
what we're talking about this digital
version that laureen's talking about is
only in this very particular
circumstance as laureen just mentioned
it's still going to be very much aligned
with
what what you would need to prepare for
so
keep preparing
keep practicing
keep practicing and i think about the
practice it's just like an athlete who
don't know when their next basketball
game is but they're probably in their
yard or in their neighborhood still
practicing free throws you keep
practicing because the more you practice
the better you're going to perform
exactly exactly and i'll this one
question from instagram which we've
already answered but i want to re-answer
it because i think it's it's worth you
know doubling down on our sat score is
going to count for anything for next
year college applications
um
lorraine you you want to take a stab at
it and i'm happy to answer it again
yeah yeah so once again you know
colleges are being flexible because they
too understand that there are some
students who are applying this fall
who won't have the opportunity to
take a test so they're taking into
account these situations but um students
should always reach out to the college
if you can take the sat you should
absolutely take the sat
because once again with the portfolio
that you have in addition to your high
school grade point average your
extracurricular activities and whatever
volunteer activities that you're
submitting sat scores will help colleges
show the skills
some students and unfortunately sal
when students sometimes hear that a
school is test optional
or sat optional they feel oh i don't
have to take the test and sometimes the
more privileged students still take it
still submit those scores and it's more
of the underserved students who don't
have a counselor coaching them to say go
ahead take the sat regardless even if
it's test optional take it and submit it
so we really encourage you if you can
take it please take it because it will
do nothing but help your portfolio and
show a better presentation of yourself
to that college admissions officer
and i'll just add to that it's
absolutely true that everyone is more
understanding and flexible right now
especially as we go into next year's
college admissions but i know a lot of
school districts have had to do things
like go to pass fail on on their letter
grades uh in this in this current
semester because of the school closures
and so that gives even less information
for colleges to make their admissions
decisions and so you can imagine it
might if you can if you're in a position
to do so it might be even more valuable
to provide those signals of of of your
your college readiness and and testing
you know i've talked to college
admissions officers of some fairly
selective schools who that went testing
optional but what you know they'll tell
you is that still a disproportionate
number of the kids who get in did take
the sat because they still need to look
at that they need some form of a signal
if you don't have something like an sat
score you're still going to have to have
some other kind of signal to the
college around your college readiness
and how it actually might uh compare
relative to other folks so i highly
highly recommend that if you're in a
position to do so and highly recommend
uh to keep preparing so we're uh pretty
much out of time lorraine uh thank you
so much uh for answering those questions
and and stay safe and healthy and i'm
glad to hear that the college board
folks are you know trying to do what
they can to to support folks through
this process
thanks al thanks for having me here
so thank you everyone for uh joining
today's live stream uh we're always
great to have a guest from some of our
partners to answer some of these
questions i know a lot of folks are
feeling a lot of stress now
the whole point of this live stream is
to try to
de-stress some of that uh and and
hopefully what you know the takeaway to
get from lorraine or from all of the
guests that we're having is we're at a
moment in the world where everyone
realizes what's important or starting to
realize uh what's important
and so
i i would just emphasize uh for folks to
uh you know do what you can put the next
foot forward
don't stress about it
and
you know things things are going to sort
out so with that
i will let you go and i look forward to
seeing all of y'all on the live stream
tomorrow
you